un matin pas comme les autres au Centre
Bell une vingtaine de joueurs de
l'équipe ukrainienne s'apprêtait à vivre
un rêve
so crazy
pisarenko c'est un moment de répit pour
tous ces jeunes qui vivent des mamans
terribles en pensant à leur famille
rester en Ukraine et alors papa qui sont
au front
il fallait voir les yeux de tous ces
jeunes qui brillaient quand les joueurs
du Canadien ont sauté sur la glace pour
l'entraînement matinal chacun avait son
favori quand on a demandé à Ivan sa
réponse était pour le moins surprenant
les jeunes ont par la suite pu
rencontrer quelques joueurs comme le
défenseur ked and Goulet Jonathan droit
et même l'entraîneur chef Martin
Saint-Louis qui était ému en conférence
de presse après sa rencontre avec les
jeunes Ukrainiens
une journée de rêve pour tous ces jeunes
une journée de trêve aussi ils ont pu
s'évader à l'instant bien loin des
horreurs de la guerre ici Robert frozi
au Centre Bell à Montréal